[Music]
in such an epic
absolute art makes its appearance prior
to this
it is an instinctive fashioning of
material submerged in the world of
determinate being
it works its way out of it and into it
it does not possess
its substance in the free ethical sphere
and therefore does not have the
character of free spiritual activity for
the self
at work later on spirit transcends art
in order to gain a higher representation
of itself that
is to be not merely the substance born
of the self but to be
in its representation as object this
self not only to give birth to itself
from its notion
but to have its very notion for its
shape so that the notion
and the work of our produced know each
other as one
and the same
paragraph 702 is a very short one coming
on the heels of
a very long one where hegel has
introduced all of this discussion
of the religion of the ethical spirit
and what that means in terms
of its artwork and here we're actually
there's a good bit going on
in this short paragraph about the
development of what
what spirit as concerned with
art and as he's going to call it
absolute art
is going to be bringing to the table and
he's drawing a comparison
between what went before which is what
we saw
as religion engaging
through the artwork through the
artificer the the worker
him or herself working upon
physical objects creating something that
could be
the object say of a cult of a religion
of a form of worship so
he talks about this as being an epic
so we have something new here we've
already commented
on the fact that hegel is very
heleno-centric and it's the greeks that
are really doing something
uh important with respect to this and
they're sort of the paradigm
and that makes sense and we could expand
this if we want to
follow out hegel's reasoning to better
understandings
of the works of art of many other
cultures as well
but he's talking about this as being an
epic and it's that word in both german
and in the english translation we have a
new period of time
a new culture a new
history happening a transition and he
says
absolute art makes its appearance
now this is very important it's not
absolute art
comes on the scene completely formed and
we know exactly what it is we recognize
it we say oh we're in a new historical
period
history doesn't work quite like that
right instead
spirit is always working behind the
scenes
and it's working behind the scenes
specifically
in terms of this artistic production
so he wants to draw this con this
contrast as we said
and here miller you know the translation
i would say leaves a little bit to be
desired
he talks about this being an instinctive
fashioning
of material oh okay that's not too bad
you know
instinct artiga arbit and our bitin
is working laboring developing
taking you know makes sense that that
miller's reading material into that
because what do you in fact work upon
and what do you make
say idols out of or ceremonial masks or
temples or whatever it's going to be you
know statuary all that kind of
interesting stuff our biden has to work
upon that and
this is something that is is really
central to
human beings we are workers of
things and also of ourselves of course
instinct artiga right so instinctive
you know arctica of the of the type
of the genre of the classification
okay we can we can call this uh
instinctual
it's not totally a matter of instinct of
course because
you know the vichmeister the
arbiter the the worker in this case
is not just some you know dumb aunt
or something like that right but it's
not
as spirit-filled we could say
as what's coming next and then he says
that
submerged into the world of determinate
being
all right well this is ins dozen and so
you've got to read quite a bit in
to call dozen existence being there
the world of determinate being but let's
let's go along
with miller's translation and hegel
and see where this is going i i think
that you know there could be an argument
for why talking about determinate
determination
right as opposed to absolute the
absolute seemingly
is unlimited right it's not
contained enclosed uh determinate
in that way so what do we have instead
he tells us here we go
um well let's finish this out it works
its way out of it and into it it works
its way in and out of existence
it does not possess its substance in
the free ethical sphere right so that's
what it's telling us we don't have at
this stage that we do have that
at this stage right so he says um
does not have the character free
spiritual activity
for the self at work and so what are we
seeing here
a greater amount of freedom
freedom to produce a different kind of
determinacy
that's not just determined by the
material that you've got in front of you
or some
vague command it's more self-conscious
it's more
able to take a creative role
in the forming and so let's keep this
ethical sphere in the front of our mind
he says
later on spirit uh transcends
art in order to gain a higher
representation of itself that's what
we're depicting
here with these different levels
to be what not merely the substance born
of the self
now what does that mean to be not merely
the substance born of the self means
that well it is
also the substance born of the self
so don't don't forget that don't say oh
we're we're not having that we're
negating that
no it is the substance born of the self
and that substance born of the self
is connected with and finds itself
within
this ethical sphere zitlikeit
right or does it like or however we want
to frame it
the realm of you can call it ethos
or more ace or customs
or the free people that has divided
itself
up into all of its different functions
all of that
is what the the self as substance is
is the substance born of it is
discovering it and all of that is a way
in which spirit
is coming to know itself but then we go
beyond that right
spirit is developing a
representation darstahlong not
forshelling here
darshan right uh it's it's uh
providing a something set out in front
of it something that's set out there
so he says later spirit transcends art
in order to gain a higher
representation of itself right to be
in its representation as object
as as gergenstan so we've got this
notion of putting something
outside of itself or beyond itself so
that it can
thereby figure out
what it is the artist the counselor
who is producing i mean unless there are
performance artists and even performance
artists have
stuff don't they right um or you know
they're doing something just
purely cognitive in their their mind or
maybe they're an
artist of affectivity no no artists
generally
are putting something outside of
themselves that is
coming from themselves and represents
something for them but it's also
connected with what they've freely
chosen to turn the eye or the ear
or the inspiration
the mind to so
representation as object this is
important as well
and he says that um here we go
not only to give birth to itself from
its
notion right so we we've got a notion a
concept a
griff and it can give it can give birth
to itself according to this notion
but here it's actually taking charge of
the notion it's
taking care of the notion it's making it
its own he says to have its very
notion for its shape
its gestalt its shape of what of
consciousness
and then he says so that the notion and
the work of art
quincy the thing that has been produced
uh know each other as one and the same
now isn't that an interesting thing to
say
so it's easy to picture
what it means for spirit or the person
or the artist even if we do it in this
very abstract sense of the notion as
shape right the shape of the artist the
shape of consciousness
the notion that they embody there's a
personality there and it's easy to say
they know themselves as the same
as the work of art that's been generated
it's easy to say what that means what
does it mean to go the other way
to say that the work of art itself
knows knows what
the the worker the artist
the intention the
spirit animating it how does that know
it's not a it's not a person now is it
well that's where we're heading now
isn't it so
we don't actually have to resolve this
at this point because we're going to do
that in the
next section to come
the ethical substance having withdrawn
from its outer existence back into its
pure self-consciousness
this is the aspect of the notion or of
the activity with which spirit brings
itself forth as
object this activity is pure form
because the individual and ethical
obedience and
service has worked off every unconscious
existence
and fixed determination in the same way
that substance itself has become this
fluid essence
this form is the night in which
substance was betrayed
and made itself into subject it is out
of this night of pure certainty of self
that the ethical spirit is resurrected
as a shape
freed from nature and its own immediate
existence
paragraph 703 is another short paragraph
in which there's
quite a lot going on that's important
for this transition that we're seeing
to the cusp where we're going to get
into some more determinate
content and movement with the abstract
work of art
and then the real center pieces of this
the later
sections or subsections within this this
religion in the form of art
section and so he talks about ethical
substance right substance is just
substance and then
ethical and all of this is it like
so the ethical substance having
withdrawn
from its outer existence what is its
outer existence well it's it's dozen
its existence as such and we're seeing
that this is going to be
mediated in large part through the
individual who's been so important in
the
reason and spirit sections this is
practical something is
happening here so he says this ethical
substance
has withdrawn from its outer existence
back into its pure
self-consciousness and this is the as he
says the
aspect or the side literally zaita
of the notion the griff
so pure self-consciousness is
you know this polarity that the
individual
him or herself has what individual are
we talking about here
well you know he doesn't tell us in this
but if we if we look ahead a bit it is
both the individual who is the
worker of art and it is also the
individual or individuals depicted
within the works of art because we're
moving gradually
in the later subsections of this into
considering
human beings considering gods who are
like human beings
and are you know to jump ahead a little
bit freed from nature
and their immediate existence in
ethical life and its predicaments so
he tells us that this is the aspect of
the notion or the
activity the tetik kite the doing things
right
it's not just a single deed it's the
capacity to do the
the activity the action
he says with which spirit brings itself
forth his object what do we mean there
well in the previous paragraph the
development that's taking place
it involves spirit engaging in
darshtelling you know sticking something
out there actually something out of
itself a bit of itself
that it can then recognize as gagenstand
as standing
against it as as imposing itself and
this is a way in which spirit can
recognize itself which remember is what
religion is
all about for hegel right so he says
that this activity
is pure form so we've got pure now in
two different ways pure
self-consciousness
pure form why and here's where we get to
something really interesting so
it's not just this notion
or spirit through its activity
generating a pure form
we also have the individual coming out
of their outer existence
through the aspect of the notion
and through some things that they're
doing what does the activity look like
the activity is ethical
zitlika obedience and service
ghorzam dinsta where have we seen those
words come up before
well the first time was in the dialectic
of master and slave
and then you know we saw we had no
resolution really there you know uh
we had to go into stoicism skepticism
unhappy consciousness the reason
section and then we got to spirit where
we have again
dialectic self-consciousnesses facing
each other
within culture now though trying to make
sense
out of their relations to each other
which are supposed to
lead them to have some sort of
recognition of mutual recognition right
so now
through ethical obedience and service
what does that have to do with art
are we talking about an apprenticeship
here no we're talking about what has
been depicted
what is the
object the gegenstand
of art and again we're not going to get
into that
right in the first subsection but by the
second one we're
definitely there so
ethical obedience and service leads us
to a
subject rather than just a
substance he says the individual in
ethical obedience and service has
worked off every unconscious existence
and fixed determination in the same way
that
substance itself has become this fluid
essence what is this fluid essence the
subject
now here is where hegel brings in some
other interesting
things to formulate this with
right he says this form is the night in
which
substance was betrayed and made itself
into subject so
something new has developed here through
this
betrayal through this finding something
more
a surplus there than what was originally
brought
it looks as if at every point right we
go from determinacy
to pure self-consciousness pure this
pure that
and that's very abstract and it's hard
to tell what that is
well by doing that by exerting the force
of the negative as hegel called it way
way back in what the preface
we find that we have substance
transformed into subject again
and he tells us that it uh it is
out of this night of what pure
certainty of self
we've seen that many times through the
previous
dialectics as well haven't we this night
of pure certainty of self where it is
betrayed that ethical spirit is
resurrected it stood back up right
as what as a shape gestalt
freed from nature in its own
immediate existence immediate existence
when mittelbar estas
right again these these aspects
uh its pure contingent existence we
could say
but also from nature now why is it
important to be
freed of nature isn't nature where we
got our raw materials from is it nature
where we got our
ideas for you know the shapes and forms
and
images that we ought to to work with yes
yes so that's
very important hegel isn't saying get
rid of nature
he is saying transcend nature culture
and religion in this case is greater
than
what is merely natural
this is something that has been known
for a very very long
time it is not something
merely modern i mean we can see this
already back in for example
simplicius in his commentary on
epictetuses
and caridian simplicius was a
neo-platonic philosopher
who says that in his commentary on
epictetus is talking about pro-euresis
the faculty of choice the thing that is
you know
definitive of us that is reflexive like
spirit
that pro-racist transcends nature
it goes beyond just what nature which
was so important for those ancients
can provide so this is a
this is a really important humanistic
theme we could say you might say what
has that got to do with religion then
well we have to sort of wait and see
where this is going to be headed
but what we have here is a dynamic
playing off of the
previous paragraph helping us to
understand better
what happened in that very long
paragraph where hegel
waxed forth in 701 about the religion of
the ethical spirit
bringing all of that stuff into play
the concrete existence of the pure
notion into which spirit has fled from
its body
is an individual which spirit selects to
be the vessel of its sorrow
spirit is present in this individual as
his universal and as the power over him
from which he suffers violence
as his pathos by giving himself over to
which his self-consciousness
loses its freedom but that positive
power of universality is subdued by the
pure self of the individual
the negative power this pure activity
conscious of its inalienable strength
wrestles with the shapeless essence
becoming its master it has made the
pathos into its material
and given itself its content and this
unity emerges
as a work universal spirit
individualized
and set before us
with paragraph 704 we round out this
introductory section to religion in the
form of art and we're getting ready to
move
into the abstract work of art and the
other
subsections that follow each of which is
going to get more and more
involved and hegel is doing some
prefiguration here
of what is yet to come he tells us that
the
concrete existence and that is existence
not does i
notice and so does it make sense to
translate it as concrete existence i
would say yes
we certainly want to demarcate it from
dozen which has been used in the
previous paragraphs to talk about
the contingent existence right
the concrete existence of the pure
notion the grief that we we saw assuming
importance in the last two
paragraphs here into which spirit
has fled from its
body now isn't that an interesting term
to bring up it's
cooper does spirit really have a body
well i guess it does if
spirit is taking possession of people or
expressing itself
through determinate human beings or this
could be
you know like the contrast between the
the body and the spirit itself maybe he
goes playing off of that
in any case he tells us it's fled from
its body so there's a movement going on
here into its concrete existence
and what is that concrete existence it
is an
individual and then here he says
something really quite interesting
so there's a metaphor here the vessel
of its sorrow or its
suffering right
spirit is selecting an individual not
every individual but an individual as
the
vessel what of its promise
of its elevation no of its
of its suffering of
its sorrow of its
sadness it selects that individual
on what basis hegel doesn't tell us here
we'll find that out as we get into more
determinate stories and
other ways of understanding art but
these are going to involve stories
so it says spirit is present in this
individual
as his universal well that sounds pretty
good doesn't it to have spirit as the
universal
in you yes and no
in this case it's actually not that good
not that good for
the individual in a certain way except
that they can be elevated
they are being picked out selected
they are being made essential they are
being made
key characters right but that universal
as as hegel says
um as the universal
and as the power over him
the force the vault the you know the
violence
from which he suffers violence as his
pathos
by giving himself over to which his
self-consciousness
loses its freedom what is hagel talking
about here is he talking about the
artist
who is working on a work of art
and it's so difficult and they pour so
much of themselves into it
not really he's talking more here again
about
character about individuals who are
taken
maybe out of history or out of the
stories that we tell
ourselves and build into epics or
whatever other cultural productions were
making of them in this case the cultural
productions of the ancient greeks
and spirit is making that person
suffer as an individual but also as the
representative
of the universal as being somebody being
something that we can identify
whether it's oedipus or his
screwed up kids who result from that
including antigone
or whether it's theseus or whether it's
who pick anyone you want right so he
goes on and he says
well actually let's let's pause on this
for a moment um
suffers violence as his pathos so what
is pathos pathos is
literally suffering uh we also use it
in ancient greek to denote the emotions
that are things that are responses right
to provocations to things happening to
us
whether they're good or bad emotions
it's also an
element you could say of drama to have
pothos
means that the thing that's happening we
we feel our way into it we respond to
that
character and their apotheosis and then
he says
giving himself over to which his
self-consciousness
pure self-consciousness we saw before
loses its freedom it becomes
stuck in the fabric of its
choices its determinancy right
so he goes on and he says that positive
power of universality
is subdued by
what the pure self of the individual the
negative power
the indeterminacy the capacity to revolt
to say no
if we want to take sort of a camusian
way of looking at this the
capacity to build something to try
something to
do something else which is a negation of
the positive
there's different kinds of negation we
can talk about they're not all
the same not every negative is the same
and
what hegel depicts here actually looks
quite positive what the individual
does how they do this he says
this pure activity conscious of its
inalienable strength
wrestles with the shapeless essence the
shapeless essence that was talked about
in the previous paragraphs
right uh what is this pure activity this
pure teti kite
um conscious of its inalienable strength
is that on the side of the universal
or is that on the side of the individual
it's the individual
in this case doing that so he says
becoming its master
and here he says meister right so this
goes back to like the
vikmeister and the you know kunsler
the artist it has made the pathos
into its material stuff it's things to
be used
it's supply you could even say right it
turned that pathos what it was suffering
it transformed it into something
intelligible something that
is meaningful and he says it's given
itself its content
and this unity emerges as a work now
what is this a unity
of universal spirit
individualized the unity of the
universal and the individual right but
it's the individual who carries this out
and set before us this is
one of the objects of the work of art
that is going to play an important role
in religion and now we're ready to move
into the next
subsection
you